as day three of the Brett Kavanaugh
hearings is in a short break right now
you look live at the committee room one
of the Democrats grilling the Supreme
Court nominee is at least trying to
project the image of someone willing to
break the rules in pursuit of the truth
but Republicans and journalists are not
so sure at least at the start of his
self-described I am Spartacus moment
this morning chief legal correspondent
an anchor of Fox News at night shannon
bream shows us what happened during
today's session which could really go
well into the night Shannon we do expect
that Brett you know today judge
Cavanaugh was confronted with his own
words with comments made by the
president asked about the Muller
investigation and much more but not
before someone else took a turn in the
spotlight this is about the closest I'll
probably ever have in my life to an I am
Spartacus moment Democratic Senator Cory
Booker opened this morning Supreme Court
confirmation hearing for judge Brett
Kavanaugh with a dramatic pledge saying
he was willing to risk expulsion from
the Senate in exchange for releasing
Kavanagh emails and documents not
released for public consumption one of
the committee's most senior members
Republican John Cornyn of Texas
cautioned Booker running for president
is no excuse for violating the rules of
the Senate or of the confidentiality of
the documents that we that we are privy
to that is irresponsible and conduct
unbecoming a senator the documents
Booker referenced her emails from
Cavanaugh's time in the bush forty three
White House in the months after 9/11
regarding internal policy debates
including a discussion about whether or
not race or national origin should be
used in national security profiling late
Wednesday night GOP Senator Mike Lee
vowed to work with Booker to get the
documents released even walking across
the room to shake on it just after 11
a.m. this morning Booker released four
documents via email and Twitter and said
this about Cornyn I think he was just
like most bullies are a lot of talk and
no action
wondering at the documents were actually
those Lee had worked with Booker to
release we reached out to Booker's
office and got no response a short time
later Senate Judiciary Committee
staffers told reporters that the
documents in question had indeed been
cleared by 4:00 a.m. and the senators
Blumenthal Booker Coons and
Lahey had been notified shortly
thereafter we again asked broker's
office for clarification about whether
or not he knew the records were cleared
for public release before he said this
if Senator Cornyn believes that I
violated Senate rules I openly invite
and accept the consequences neither a
spokesman for the senator or mr. Booker
himself would answer our questions about
when he knew the documents were ready
for public release and rather than
praising bipartisan efforts to get the
documents released Booker told us this
and then they rushed actually subverting
their own process they rushed to then
release him after I shamed them publicly
meanwhile Cavanaugh continued to field
questions on hot-button issues like roe
v-- wade the Supreme Court has
recognized the right to abortion since
the 1973 roe v wade case has reaffirmed
it many times and the molar
investigation I've never given anyone
any hints for cast previews winks
nothing about my view as a judge or how
I would rule as a judge as for that
email discussing the possible use of
race or national origin in national
security profiling you could see in the
emails Cavanaugh actually is one of
those who is advocating for a
race-neutral policy so supporters of his
say this idea of Booker pushing to
release the documents actually ended up
helping the nominees Brad Warren this
with the panel Shannon thank you